in a far away place
there's a magical time
when the sun never sets
now way up north
take a giant leap
and swoop through scandinavia's arctic
circle
for a season of sunshiny days
norway sweden
finland but be quick
the light bright magic doesn't last
long at the top
of the world
[Music]
svalbard archipelago this is
inside the arctic circle
and as far north as norway gets
it's the kind of place most people think
of
when they hear arctic
[Music]
svalbard is a cluster of extraordinary
islands
and icebergs full of life
female walrus have migrated north
preferring to chase the thick eyes
that they love so much
but the males stay here and look for
places to hang out for summer
kicking back in svalbard has its
disadvantages
for the males they're exposed
to predators
polar bears
this one has already killed the walrus
he'll eat as much as 20 of his body
weight
in a sitting then once
it's done time again to look for fresh
meat
polar bears hold the title as the
world's
largest land predators but in reality
they track their food on water
frozen water
they use the eyes as a platform from
which to hunt
jumping from ice flow to ice flow
now that most of the day has sunshine
their eyes is getting thin
[Music]
they can shake off a quick dip in the
freezing water
without fuss
so walrus and seals are right to worry
when there's a bear around
they have just one consolation
polar bears don't rest in winter like
other bears
but in summer they may fast for months
at a time
this is how summer plays out in this
northernmost
outpost of norway
but travel south and there's more to the
arctic
than you know
svalbard is an outpost of norway
in the country's far north
but the arctic circle is much more
an invisible line that rings the top of
the globe
at 66 degrees 33 minutes
north the scandinavia section
covers about 150 000 square miles
and it's topped by the north cape
monument
the northernmost point of mainland
europe
this is the end of the earth
the north cape monument sits atop a
thousand foot
high plateau
and looks out to where the atlantic
meets
the arctic ocean
[Music]
everywhere in the arctic circle just had
at least a month of perpetual darkness
but in february the light returns
and now you can see the northernmost
points
of scandinavia's mainland
at the very bottom of the arctic circle
spring has already cleared the snow from
the peaks
here in norway the arctic becomes
a hiker's paradise
[Music]
this is
several hundred remote islands
cliffs to the north are an annual summer
retreat for one of the strangest
creatures
in the arctic
around 160 000 puffins
vacation here for a couple of months
every year
summer is the puffins breeding season
when they get to know each other
[Music]
they build nests in rock crevices and in
holes among the stones
and of course fill up on fish
they are capable flyers and even better
swimmers
and puffins are one of the few birds
that can hold many fish
in their beaks at once
their raspy tongues give them just the
right kind of grip
so they can bring back fresh fish for
their young
puffins usually made for life and both
parents will share the responsibility of
caring for their own
similar to penguins the flightless birds
of the other pole but despite their
similar colors
they are not related
[Music]
the puffins bright colored bills match
their feet
but only during the mating season
before summer is done they'll shed that
colorful
outer layer and head back out to sea
with
smaller dull colored beaks
while they don't mind chatting up a
storm now
[Music]
once at sea they remain perfectly silent
meanwhile some of the fish they like to
hunt
have their own summer plants
millions head inland along the great
waterways of scandinavia's arctic
[Music]
they returned from the ocean and charged
[Music]
upstream
among them grayling
[Music]
these are relics of the last ice age
and they perform an annual ritual of
frenzied egg laying
here two males flank a female
[Music]
and both try to fertilize her eggs at
the same time
[Music]
[Music]
the volume of life in these pristine
waters
during summer attracts fishermen from
all over scandinavia
the tama river is one of the few places
where they can still use nets
sometimes following the traditional
methods
of the sami people who've lived here for
at least
two thousand years
around the world summer signals a time
for water sports
and the arctic circle is no different
the potential thrills outweigh the
chills for arctic surfers
the waves roll in all the way from
greenland it's the most reliable surf
in northern europe and that makes it a
magnet
for die hard board riders like local
tommy olsen and his son
you have these point breaks which in
circling terms is like really good
the wave breaks all the time on the same
spot
normally i have like one or two but here
you have like three point breaks and
also a beach break
the gulf stream keeps this arctic water
between
46 and 58 degrees year round
but the air temperature can easily dip
below
freezing
[Music]
for tommy the chill and the challenge
is worth it it's quite unique
you know the waves are really
world-class ways
but the thing is the backdrop the
scenery is really different from
other surf spots
people have come from all over the world
to serve here
since the sixties and lofoten has
the world's northernmost surf schools
there are two of them in town
the surfers ride as long as there are
waves and light
and up here the sun in summer can shine
24 hours
a day
this endless summer makes up for that
time of year
when the lights once again go off
ice and cold take over the land as early
as
[Music]
august
the days get shorter 15 minutes less
light
every day
[Music]
and that makes what arctic surfers do
next
even more amazing
arctic surfers still find their way to
the waves
even as summer wanes
now at night they can be guided by the
beguiling green
of the northern lights
it's the kind of magic you can only find
near the poles
[Music]
on the ground the arctic circle is
marked by little more than an occasional
road and this visitor center
that stays open until the beginning of
october
when the roads and paths become clogged
with snow
and the trees become ice sculptures
it's time to release the house
[Music]
dog sledding is popular across
scandinavia
and races are the arctic circles grand
prix
perhaps even more grueling
some of the events cover more than 700
miles
and last for five or six days
training for such marathons begins as
soon as the snow sets in
even if it's still technically summer
eight dogs to a sled and they run as
smooth as silk
this mold of transport has been around
for at least 1 000
years
erwal arminson the norwegian explorer
who became the first person to reach the
south pole
achieved his epic journey thanks to such
hard-working
canine companions
[Music]
[Music]
when it's all done the reward is a
release from the harness
[Music]
up the only march now
is dinner
the sled drivers are a diverse group
[Music]
but the dogs must be billed for arctic
extremes
so much so that these breeds happily
live in their outdoor kennels year-round
no matter the weather
[Music]
the wild animals in the arctic circle
don't have the luxury of a kennel
and in this world of white they stand
out
an orderly line of reindeer heads north
at the end of summer
as they roam they look for patches of
lycan or moss
to dig up from beneath the arctic snow
the sun may look like it's setting but
up here in early autumn this is what
passes for midday
in about a month the sun will rise at
all and this whole wonderland will
plunge
into a month of darkness
before that happens there's work to do
[Music]
the sami people of northern norway have
heard it reindeer here
for at least a thousand years
it's not so much of a job it's more like
a lifestyle
hurting the reindeers you get like a
deep
connection to the nature and respect for
the nature
[Music]
so
now with the help of machines and dogs
they give the animals a nudge
in the right direction through
temperatures
of minus 40 degrees
somehow the reindeer actually doesn't
even mind
the cold weather
reindeer has a special kind of hair
it's like a pipe it has holes in it and
it
insulates much better than other types
of hair on
other animals
[Music]
so
all summer the reindeer have been free
to graze
now the sami round them up for a twice
annual checkup they've covered 20 miles
today
to get this sea of antlers into a corral
and now they're nearly there
when we start moving the renderer to the
corrals
a lot of family members and friends come
and help us
it looks like midnight but it's only
around
five in the afternoon
as the reindeer run in a circle the
herders
size them up and separate them into
different groups
some will get veterinary care some will
get ear tags or collars for tracking
others will be sectioned off for market
reindeer skin horns and bone are all
important products for the sami people
and they've traditionally depended on
them for survival
and the story goes there's another
traditional use
for reindeer
reindeer sleds in this part of finland
lead
to one place
a tiny hamlet famous for one
resident
[Music]
this is santa village with everything
christmas inside including santa
it's a tourist not so hot spot open
all year round for those who just can't
wait
for december
[Music]
finding a warm place to stay after
summer
can be a challenge
but since 2008 there's been the option
of the now world famous 30 room large
snow hotel
starting in early september artists
rebuild the accommodations by packing
snow
into blocks
they have supersized the idea of a
traditional
igloo
[Music]
the cocktails at this bar are all served
chilled
dining area
bedrooms
even a chapel all
sheltered from the outer elements and
kept at a relatively toasty temperature
just a few degrees below freezing
these are the creature comforts of the
arctic circle
but outside it's more about the
creatures
[Music]
they have their own ways of coping with
the chill or autumn
and some of them are downright deadly
up in the arctic circle links
seem to welcome the early snow and they
are well built for it
their long legs and wide webbed feet
allow them to move
quickly across the powder
and it takes more than a light snow to
chill them through that thick fur
by autumn the spring kittens are big
enough to keep up with mum
but make no mistake about who's still in
charge
especially when moms found a scrap of
squirrel
[Music]
they spent their summer being nurtured
by her
but no more
that's links for wake your turn junior
one day these twins will be just as
assertive with their own young
until then they can practice fighting
with each other
these kittens are fully weaned but may
stay with their mother
for another year when they finally head
out without her
they may stick close for a few months
working together
across the arctic landscape
and even up the trees
eventually though they'll separate
entirely
and lead the solitary life of a lone
predator
searching for food in the wild north
if they become very good hunters
there are plenty of menu options out
here
[Music]
reindeer shelter among the trees
summer was easy pickings
now they must search hard for new places
to rest
or graze
[Music]
when they catch a sniff of danger they
have a plan
[Music]
they use a nearby frozen over river
like a freeway they are able to move
fast
through the terrain and just as well
they run for a reason
not far behind a small pack of arctic
walls
wolves are the second largest predator
in western europe
only bears are bigger
packs can be 30 strong three
is small but that's more than enough to
take down a straggler
the young and the weak are their
specialty
wolves can easily cover 12 miles a day
and the reindeer have made it easier for
them
creating trails through the snow
as they go they mark their territory
with urine
and sometimes feces for wolves
this is a form of communication
interlopers
beware
today the reindeer had the upper hand
and the pace of the chase is not worth
it
summer was good to this wolf pack trio
no need to push it just yet
the wolves take a break
there are three some arctic predators
and even the giants
up here must try to stay out of their
way
this moose mother and her year old calf
search
for food in norway's arctic circle
their cloven hooves spread widely to
support them
over the soft snow those long legs
can carry them through rough terrain
yet they can move as quietly as a cat
it's an extraordinary achievement for
their size
but important in helping them to avoid
predators
summer is over and the posture is buried
but there's plenty of light and still a
lot to dine
[Music]
they live on lichen that grows on trees
if they can they'll also stretch their
powerful necks upwards
to grab pine needles but it's the
nibbling of the nether regions
that got them the name
moose is derived from moosh a native
american word that means stripper and
eater
of bark
[Music]
vacation time is over but there's still
a couple of months before the creatures
of the arctic
circle are plunged into darkness
they must work with what light they have
left
every week the days grow shorter by more
than an hour
[Music]
white-tailed eagles were nearly pushed
to extinction throughout the region
but they've been able to keep a toe hole
along the coast
norway has the highest density of
white-tailed eagles
in europe
with good light it's a fish-finding
frenzy
not all the fish here are such hard work
eco safari guides like trikvistan
serve up the sushi as fishermen have
done here for
hundreds of years
visitors can get a close look at some of
this area's
300 nesting couples
it's a majestic bird indeed also an
unpredictable bird
they are able to make their own choices
[Music]
some of the white-tailed eagles from
lufford have been captured and relocated
to bolster populations
elsewhere in europe and the uk
that's helped spread the word and made
this area a hot spot for bird watchers
[Music]
the fish they snatch are herring
and norway is famous for the millions of
herring that migrate through here
every autumn
fishing trawlers wait for them
so too age old predators
the birds signal the catch is good
soon enough around the boat
giants
humpback whales come in to take their
share
the fishermen tighten their nets to haul
in their catch
but inevitably some herring escape
and the humpbacks swoop by to collect
them
each of these giants can be more than 50
feet long
and weigh up to 40 tons
and they can eat a ton of food a day
sometimes large amounts of the timeless
creatures
like krill other times like here
scraps of herring do just fine
[Music]
this feast is too rich for just one
whale species
to enjoy
the fjords of norway plunge steep and
deep
into the sea so orca don't mind coming
in
close to land they stand out
in a crowd with fins that can be more
than
six feet high
these social creatures can travel in
pods up to 30 strong
they joined their hump cousins for the
feast
and if two mammal species swimming for
their supper here isn't enough
don't worry here comes a third
[Music]
while the rest of scandinavia may be
hunkered down preparing for winter
and its darkness the sea is where you
can still find
a hearty meal
the gulf stream keeps the water around
the fjords
virtually ice free that's what brings in
the fish
and the divers we're really
really really lucky to live in this
place on the earth
we have the gulf current hitting the
shore here
the water is constantly between 15 and
60 degrees celsius and the nutrition of
the water here
it's it has a really really rich life
both for mammals and for fish
aryan dunes and his dive buddies use
modern gear and can stay in the water
for a few hours without getting too
cold they seek out flat fish
pollock haddock and especially cod
we um planning each dive before we go
into the water
what kind of fish we do want to look for
everything like in the sea comes really
close to you
especially when you're a freediver
free divers don't use tanks but can hold
their breath
for several minutes at a time
you have to keep all your sensors open
because the fish senses you you know in
your excitement
and it triggers all your instincts when
you go in the water
in the 1960s there was a push to make
spear fishing an olympic sport
that failed but the fish here continue
to attract divers
you can catch fish all year here and
there's probably plenty enough fish to
feed my whole family and the neighbors
and their neighbors again
so i shoot a lot of fish here and i give
them away to my neighbors and give them
away to my family
yeah it's really nice really nice
the biggest fish come to the lower
regions
of the arctic circle in winter
but one of the strangest looking species
never leaves
no matter how dark it gets
[Music]
the vibrant atlantic wolf fish or
sea wolf resembles an eel
with one long fin down its back
but its real magic is on the inside
the wolf fish produces a kind of
anti-freeze
for its blood so it can live in the icy
arctic
all year round even now in the depths
of winter
it dines on shellfish and starfish and
the like
which he can rip into with savage teeth
they are one of the few fish to have
both parents
care for their eggs they guard them for
several
months until they hatch
their home here in the arctic circle is
also unique
it's the world's largest known cold
water reef
with all this color it's hard to believe
it's been dark up top for more than two
months
except perhaps for the returning shimmer
of the northern lights
then once again a glimmer of
sunlight and warmth
starts to melt the snow
these extremes of the arctic circle
force
humans
and creatures
to toughen them up
they must adapt to conditions
and embrace hardship
but once a year like magic
the veil of darkness lifts throughout
the region
the ice melts away and the arctic has
come
full circle
time again to decide how to spend your
summer vacation
holidays in the arctic are short
but that's why they may be more prized
here
than anywhere else on the planet
[Music]
you